the outpouring of grief in this
constituency has been overwhelming
huge numbers turned out to pay their
respects at this candlelit vigil young
and old united in remembrance of a
widely loved mp
sir david amos was also a husband and
father
this picture was taken a few weeks ago
at his daughter alexandra's wedding
and in the community others are
reflecting on his spirituality as a man
of the faith this holy celebration of
the mass will be offered for
our
beloved petitioner
sir david amis
we're all saddened
shocked because this man is so dear to
everyone at the catholic church where he
worshipped a mass held in his memory
father alex pogblodor and many in the
congregation were his friends the shock
at what happened is still raw
many people here are finding it hard to
understand why such a kind man was
targeted
i just hope and pray that
together with the community
they will also be able to accept this
as something that
cannot be forgotten
and amidst all the grief there is a
fast-moving police investigation a
warrant of further detention has been
granted and a 25 year old man remains in
custody it's understood by sky news he's
called ali habi ali the incident is
being treated as an act of terrorism
forensic officers are still working
inside the church where the attack took
place whilst he was holding a
constituency surgery now the murder has
provoked a huge outpouring of grief on
both sides of the police corridor many
people have been laying tributes this
one down here is typical of what so many
people have been saying it reads may god
embrace you now as you look down on the
town you were so proud to represent
across south end flags have been lowered
an mp for 38 years said david's impact
has been huge on this constituency i
think it's safe to say we're a community
and grieving councillor alex bright a
friend and colleague told me the loss
has cast a long shadow over this seaside
town he was missed the south end i think
it's probably the best way to put it
i've known sir david since i was 13.
he has always been a constant here in
south end not just for me but for
everybody here and in the conservative
party here in south end
the nature of this attack has
intensified the debate over the safety
of mps the home secretary is ordering an
urgent review but for now many people
here just want to grieve a decent man
who touched so many lives
alex rossi sky news
leon c